So where are you from?
Oh,
Brazil has funded Hablo Espanol out.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about
Portuguese.
Portuguese is a language that far too
often gets ignored in Canada.
If you tell someone you want to study
Portuguese,
they might say,
oh,
isn't that kind of like Spanish or worse
yet?
They might say,
why Portuguese?
Why don't you study Spanish instead?
And I'm sure Portuguese speakers just
love that.
The truth is that Portuguese is one of
the world's major languages with between
215 and $220 million people.
It is the second most widely spoken
romance language after Spanish,
like Spanish.
It is so widely spoken because it spread
to the four corners of the globe during
the colonial period.
It is the only official language in
Portugal,
Brazil,
Mozambique,
Angola,
Cape Verde,
Guinea,
Bissau,
Saulteaux,
may,
and principate and it's co official in
East Timor,
Ecuadorian Guinea and Macau,
like all romance languages.
Portuguese developed from Vulgar Latin,
which was the spoken Latin used during
the Roman Empire together with Castilian
Spanish along with Galician.
And a few other languages,
it forms the Iberico Romance Branch of
the Romance Language family.
It's called [inaudible] romance because
it's located on the Iberian peninsula
when the Romans conquered the Iberian
peninsula,
vulgar,
lax,
and began to be spoken there,
and it started to diverge gradually over
time into different regional dialects.
And by the 10th century,
those dialects had diverged enough to be
considered separate languages,
but Portuguese didn't exactly exist yet,
and Alisha and Portuguese also known as
Old Portuguese existed.
Galician Portuguese diverged into two
separate modern languages,
Galician and Portuguese by about the
16th century,
although they're still quite similar
from what I hear.
The language received its name,
Portuguese in the year 1290,
when the king of Portugal opened the
first university in Portugal and he
decided that the language of instruction
would not be Latin,
but would be the vulgar Latin,
the spoken language,
and he decided to call that language
Portuguese.
Portugal was still a relatively new
kingdom at that time,
and the language had never been called
Portuguese yet.
It was just called vulgar Latin and it
was not yet very distinct from the
vulgar Latin spoken in Galicia in the 15
hundreds when the newly developed
printing press helped make Portuguese a
standardized language.
Portugal had already started exploring
and colonizing different areas of the
world,
bringing their language with them.
The net result is this,
Portuguese is spoken by around 10
million people in Portugal,
but it is much more dispersed around the
world.
It is spoken by $205 million people in
Brazil and then of course there's Africa
in Angola.
It is the native language of about 5
million people,
20 percent of the population,
but it's also widely used as a lingua
franca that unites the countries,
different ethnic groups.
That is about 15 million more second
language speakers,
Cape Verdi,
500,000
people speak a Portuguese based creole
as their native language,
but they learn Portuguese as a second
language for official purposes.
Also in Guinea Bissau the most common
language is a Portuguese creole,
but Portuguese is also an official
language with around 200,000
native speakers.
In Mozambique.
There are one point $9 million native
speakers and another 10 million who
speak it as a second language in south
Romania and prints EPA.
It is spoken by another 120,000
people as a native language in
Equatorial Guinea.
It was made an official language in
recent years though nobody really speaks
it.
I think they did that to promote their
relations with other Portuguese speaking
countries in the area and let's not
forget Asia,
Portuguese as a co official language in
East Timor,
which was a Portuguese colony until
1975.
Nowadays it is a co official language
again,
but mostly only older people can speak
it and they are almost all second
language speakers also in Macau.
Portuguese is spoken by zero point six
percent of the population as a native
language and it's also spoken by some
elderly people as a second language,
but not so much these days.
There are also the former Portuguese
colonies in India specifically go up and
do you.
Portuguese is spoken by some people
there,
but the numbers are quite small these
days.
There were also a Portuguese creole
spoken in Malacca,
Malaysia Florists.
Indonesia,
Batticaloa,
Sri Lanka and Aruba,
if we include the second language
speakers than there are about 250 to 260
million speakers of Portuguese.
That does not include the creole
languages.
Portuguese is the sixth most widely
spoken language in the world and it is
also the most widely spoken language in
South America even though it's only
spoken in one country there.
Brazil,
there are different accents and dialects
of Portuguese,
but the main through categories are
European,
Portuguese which is spoken in Portugal
and Brazilian Portuguese which is spoken
in Brazil.
Brazilian Portuguese is similar to 18th
century Portuguese and also has some
influences from the Indian languages and
African languages of the people who were
present in Brazil.
I've read a lot of comments by lots of
different people about this,
but it seems like the difference between
Brazilian and European.
Portuguese is basically like the
difference between UK English versus
American English.
There is different accents,
different pronunciation.
There are some different vocabulary
words and idioms and some of the grammar
is slightly different,
but basically they are the same language
and are intelligible.
They'll sometimes,
depending on your exposure to the other
variety of the language,
you might have some trouble
understanding or communicating which one
is better to study.
Well,
most students have Portuguese seemed to
say that Brazilian Portuguese is easier
to learn and on top of that,
Brazil has a huge population of over 200
million people and you're much more
likely to meet Brazilians around the
world.
Then you are Portuguese people in my
experience on top of that,
Brazilian soap operas are very popular
around the world and they make people in
all Portuguese speaking countries,
quite familiar with Brazilian
Portuguese,
so in my opinion,
the best one to learn as Brazilian
Portuguese unless you have a specific
plan to visit or live in Portugal and
there might be some other reasons.
I've preferred Brazilian Portuguese,
but there's no need to get into that
right now.
Did you know the Iberian peninsula was
under Islamic rule for several hundred
years and during that time Portugal
absorbed some influence from the Arabic
language and that includes about 800
vocabulary words of Arabic origin.
Something similar happened to Spanish
too.
There are also some Portuguese words
that have made their way into the
English vocabulary.
For example,
breeze,
cashew,
Cobra,
embarrass flamingo,
some food like Marmalade,
molasses,
tapioca and the insect mosquito.
Like most romance languages,
Portuguese has a lot of vocabulary that
is recognizable to English speakers
because of the French and Latin
influence on English.
Let's look at a Portuguese sentence and
I'll show you what I mean.
Okay.
Forgive my pronunciation here guys.
Taylor swift that you mock on.
Dora instrument prototype forum was Eco
North America now,
so let's look at some of the words here.
A controller,
what that looks like.
The English word camp tour,
which is someone who recites music in a
synagogue or church.
I think so.
I think that Cantata is a singer.
He told her,
well,
that looks like a composer.
So I think that means musical composer,
instrument Tiesta.
Well,
I think that looks like instrumentalist
or musician and prototype that looks
like a producer.
So prototype was eco,
must've been musical producer and then a
three step must be an actress and not
the medical center that looks like North
American.
So if you look at all of those words and
just kind of analyze each word,
you can figure out the meaning of that
sentence pretty easily.
A lot of Portuguese sentences are like
that though.
They're not always that simple,
but I gave you a simple example just to
show you that you can often recognize
words like that so you can probably
learn to read some Portuguese fairly
easily.
If you an English speaker and if you
know another romance language,
then you can probably already read a lot
of it without having studied the
language.
Of course,
learning to speak it and to write it
will require focus and effort because
that means you have to actually produce
the phonology and produced the grammar
as you have to with any language.
So stop thinking of Portuguese as the
strange little brother of Spanish.
It's actually an important global
language that stands on its own.
Thank you for watching the [inaudible]
channel.
If you are interested in Portuguese and
in Brazil,
make sure you also check out my video on
Brazil,
on my other channel,
Geo Focus and it's right here.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.
Yeah.